No more
nothing.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us in
he says subhanahu wa ta'ala
regarding the people of the book the
Jews the Christians those who were given
the revelations of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
and then proceeded to
ignore more much of that which was
revealed to them
and proceeded to divide
amongst one another out of spite towards
one another
out of
arrogance between one another.
this happened
and such differing should not have
occurred.
Why is that?
He says subhanahu wa'ta'ala regarding
the people of the book the Jews the
Christians
he said subhanahu wa'tala
and the people of the book they did not
divide up amongst each other and group
up into different
groups and factions.
and u opinions that were fighting and
contradicting one another in their
understanding of the core principles of
their revelation. They only did this
after their messengers came to them,
after their respective messengers came
to them.
However, this should never have
happened. Why? Because what should have
united them all underneath all of that
was the basic tenants of their religion
which was they were not commanded except
that they worship Allah
making sincere to him all of their
worship
and follow and adhere to their
messengers.
This is what they were commanded and
that they establish salah and that they
give zaka and that is the straight
religion of Allah.
That is the religion of Allah. What does
that mean? Every prophet and messenger
came with that core message.
If we were to have a devout follower
of Musam
amongst us today or Isa or NIM
or L or H or or any one of these Muslims
from those past nations,
if they were amongst us today, the
details of their worship will be
different than ours. The details will be
different.
However, the core tenants would be
exactly the same. There'd be no
difference between us and them in the
core tenants of the religion.
Meaning we would all agree on the
worship of Allah alone without any
partners, making sincere to him all acts
of worship and that we should only
worship in the way that our respective
prophets taught us. That is the religion
of Allah from the time of Adam
until the last human being on this
earth. This is what we were created for.
There was never any deviation from that
and there was never any confusion in
that from the messengers and the
prophets and the scholars. The confusion
came when people started to twist and
play with the religion of Allah
for worldly gain or personal gain or
because their mind had become warped by
presuppositions
presupposing something and then looking
for evidence for that thing in the Quran
and Sunnah.
This is what we refer to and we call
innovation. That's what innovation is.
And so when these
groups,
when these nations, these followers of
the prophets started to fight with each
other and started to compete with each
other.
What did they start to do? They started
to contradict each other for the mere
point of contradicting one another.
And for this reason, Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala said regarding those who differ
in their religion, listen to this verse.
He says,
he says indeed
those who have
differed
and divided
in their religion.
You are not of them in any way. He was
speaking to the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam.
Indeed those who differ in their
religion and contradict one another and
split up into factions in groups you oh
Muhammad have nothing to do with them.
Nothing to do with them in this life and
in the hereafter. Nothing to do with
them.
Meaning all of them will claim that
Muhammad sallall.aii wasallam is their
prophet and they follow him. However,
it's not about claiming
to be the follower of Muhammad
sallall.aii.
It's about if Muhammad claims you.
This is what matters.
It's not about if you claim to love
Allah. Everybody claims to love Allah.
That's not unique at all. Every human
being claims that. Speak to anyone who
believes in Allah and has not learned
their belief from from Allah.
No matter how wicked or evil they are,
they will tell you, "I'm sure that God
is happy with me. I'm sure that he's
fine with me. Right? You look you you
look even to disbelievers,
people that worship other than Allah,
atheists, people who disbelieve in
Allah,
they claim paradise for each other
always
say, "Well, you know,
God rest his soul. I'm sure he's in a
better place now." How do you know that?
What did this person do to find himself
in a better place,
right? And so the claim
that you love Allah, everybody claims
that.
What is the notable thing is if Allah
claims to love you, if he loves you,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
to them to your followers, tell them if
you all claim to love Allah, then follow
me and Allah will in turn love you.
to lay claim to the love of Allah. This
is not unique. It's whether Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala loves you back. To
lay claim to the prophet Muhammad
sallall.aii wasallam is not unique.
Every single person does that. It's
whether he lays claim to you in this
life and in the hereafter. That is what
matters. Everything else falls to the
wayside.
So when we look at this verse,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us that
these people of the book, they differed
with each other.
And you, oh Muhammad, you are not of
them in any way. And those who follow
you, but differ with one another in the
essential core values of
the religion of Islam.
You are not of them in any way.
He says subhanahua.
It's interesting because this verse in
Indeed, those who
those who divide up their religion
and become split into factions and
waring groups in that religion, you are
not of them in the least. It's
interesting because this verse has
another recitation
which is as well correct.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
and the house for
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
sent down another recitation of this
verse and that is in the first
recitation indeed those who divide up
their religion and turn into waring
differing factions.
You oh Muhammad are not of them in the
least. And then another recitation
indeed those who
depart from their religion. Depart.
Depart. What does that mean? The first
one indeed those who divide up their
religion. And the other recitation
indeed those who depart from their
religion. What does that mean? It means
that as soon as a person innovates
and hence divides up the religion of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala immediately
they depart with the religion of Allah
immediately because these are two
opposites they cannot come together
they cannot simultaneously
exist in the same place and in the same
time you cannot divide up the religion
of Allah and still be part of the
religion of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And so we understand from this
that the dividing up of the religion
comes as a result
of the
of the departure of mankind from the
religion of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And we're not speaking about differences
of opinion on issues
regarding
issues of issues that the scholars of
Islam differ on.
That is considered to be of
interpretation. We're not speaking
about that. We're speaking about
differing on the core tenants of Islam,
differing on the of Allah,
differing on innovation,
differing on the belief and beliefs with
regards to the names and attributes of
Allah,
differing
in aspects
of the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam's legacy which is not open to
debate. Introducing newly invented
matters, innovation,
these are things that are not open for
discussion
and they are not unclear which is an
oxymor. It's a double negative. They are
incredibly clear crystal clear. As a
matter of fact, a lot of times we when
we look at, you know, we read something
online or we hear people talk and we
think that everything in Islam is a
difference of opinion and it's not a big
deal. If you don't understand something
as from Islam and you go to look it up
and you start reading things that you're
not prepared to read yet and you don't
go through the scholars of Islam to
learn your religion many of us or
most of us today. You have an issue, you
have a question, you go and you type it
into Google and you start to read
articles and from god knows where
written by god knows who, right?
You start to read and this is a
difference of opinion and that's a
difference of opinion and this is a
difference of opinion. What do you what
conclusion does the average person come
to when you see that over and over and
over? What conclusion do you come to?
Everything's a difference of opinion.
You know what that means? Nothing
nothing makes sense. Nothing is clear.
Everything is unclear.
Everything is open to debate. Everything
is open to discussion. Even the scholars
don't know what's really going on.
That's the conclusion you come to. Even
if only subconsciously.
And so
when we start to take on this belief or
this understanding and it starts to
creep up, we start to not differentiate
between anything. As long as some
scholar said it from god knows where.
it's valid. That is not how it works at
all.
And the ex the exact
example of that would be if I was not
trained in medicine. I'm not a doctor.
And I start to crack open advanced
medical books and start to read about
all kinds of different opinions that
doctors have had throughout the
centuries, right? and current
differences of opinion and read in
statistics and read in studies and I
have no idea what I'm reading. What does
that mean? That doesn't mean that what
I'm reading every single thing is
translated into action. A doctor would
understand these things very simple and
they can come to a conclusion and
knowledge is clear to him. Contrary to
someone me, I don't know where to
start or where to end, how to make heads
or tails of this. I have no business
reading that.
I have no business reading that. And so
to end here, the point that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala is driving home to
us is that differing
amongst one another in the essential
values of Islam and in the essential
issues of Islam
and in the main tenants of belief and
tenants of Islam.
This only comes as a result of
innovation. Allah would not hold us
accountable for something that we are
not guilty of. And so when Allah holds
accountable
people for dividing up their religion,
that means that they had no right to do
that and it was clear. And I will tell
you just how clear the Quran and Sunnah
is. I'll end with this narration. The
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam tells us
just how clear his sunnah is.
Forget about all these things that you
read
you know difference of opinion and
some scholars say this and some scholars
say that. These are studies that only
students of knowledge and scholars are
supposed to be reading. These things are
not meant to be translated and exported
to the masses of layman people in the
world. If a person has a question, they
come to the scholar, they ask him, they
take what he says and they implement it.
They want to learn what is behind that.
They have to now take a path to seek
knowledge. You don't get to just ask
anything and get the answer in the way
that you want.
And so if we were to look at Islam in
that way, the Quran and its most obvious
interpretation is clear. The Sunnah and
its most obvious interpretation is very
clear. This is how clear the sunnah is.
The prophet sallallah.aii wasallam said
inb
[Silence]
This is how clear the prophet's religion
and sunnah is. He said, "I have left you
all behind on the clear, straight,
unmistakable
path.
And it is so clear that its night is
just as bright as its day.
The path that the prophet has le left us
on
its night
is just as bright as its day.
Meaning even the things which are
differed upon and slightly unclear are
in essence crystal clear. They are not
unclear enough to not be able to
recognize the path of Muhammad sall.ai
Wasam.
I have left you all at behind me on the
path of Allah. The clear unmistakable
path of Allah. Its night is just as
clear and bright as its day. The only
person that will step off of this path
after my departure is someone who is
bound for hell. The misguided. That is
the only kind of person. We ask Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
that he subhanahu wa ta'ala teach us of
the Quran and what we are ignorant of
and that he benefit us from that which
he teaches us of them.
me which is equal.